okay on to the next game
opponent is called black sim from brazil
and i try to get to the zamish again
i guess via transposition
okay it's unusual
maybe just e4
immediately
okay
i need to do something about
e4 of course f3
looks a bit slow
maybe it may be creamy too
not very well developed i try
a3
of course you can also take on d4 now
that would lead to really unusual pawn
structure after ab4
dc bc
check yeah
yeah it's an interesting really
interesting position
yeah i guess i have to take then e5
then of course he's got knight e4 which
is
a bit unpleasant
because c3 is just hanging
and he also has got maybe f6 at some
point
yeah i don't like this position a lot i
have to admit
it looks really underdeveloped but he
needs to play f6
to really um
open up the position
if you play some slow moves it might be
okay
of course you could play knight c6 for
instance this was also
would also be okay but i guess f6 is the
the main problem
hmm yeah maybe he wants to play f6 and
then
then take with the knight
yeah anyway i have to get some
development
going here
unfortunately on f6 oh he really wants
to prepare this
i guess
hmm interesting
f6
maybe i have to really play um
more directly here
like take a knight g5 for instance
maybe the knight f8
interesting i i think i i need to do
this
otherwise you'll just play f6 and
blow up the position
of course is also looking dangerous but
my development is not not very good
but i just need castling to
to consolidate here
hmm
yeah what now d4 is just hanging
yeah i need to protect this
yeah yeah black is fine here of course
he always had had um queen d5 as well
this is why i didn't go for bishop c3
because i simply won't win e4
he always has 95 uh queen d5
and this is just just a good position
for black
yeah of course
yeah i need to cover this
i was only thinking about some
positional ideas not
not about um about the exchange of
course
okay then i'll have to go for
for some attack here
it doesn't take okay
yeah understa understand the rationale
behind this
time warning still
yeah this is a nice a nice night yeah
i'm sure
still i'm not sure
this wasn't the best um way to play
this is a playable again for white
rook d2 g3 to come
and now i just have d5
or haven't i
do
yeah i don't see a good move for black
the main issue will be the time
once again i guess
yeah this should should really be enough
check
check
check
check
check black forfeits on time
yeah very close and the position was
of course very bad for me
but it was completely unnecessary for
him
um to
to go for this of course
it's still looking pretty okay for black
from optical point of view but still
it's an extra pawn and he's got really
problems to
to keep the knight on d5 because it's
only protected by the queen and so the
queen
cannot move freely and i just put the
things on the g
file of course this was bad but
i'm not sure what he what he should play
in this position for instance he could
simply play queen d5 and
with a very good position then rook c8
and so on he's just got the c
fire and i've got a bad knight on h3
very good position for black